hey guys welcome back to Westeros weekly
if you're new here this is the show that
answers your biggest questions about
every episode of Game of Thrones I'm
Phillip Melina and I'm Erik Bosse oh my
god we waited almost two years for the
final season and it's here episode 1 of
season 8 all the Starks are back in
Winterfell we're getting dragon flying
lessons it's How to Train Your Dragon 8
and everyone is also giving a bunch of
side-eye oh yeah yeah we're kind of like
that little kid at the beginning of the
episode is like trying to peek through
and get our look at all of our favorite
characters back again like get on my way
grandma you're blocking my view of the
unsullied I literally shoved my
grandmother so yeah speaking of things
your grandmother hates about you you
could listen to us in many other ways
there's a coverage that we have now as a
podcast so you can get this show Erik's
episode breaks downs and all of our
other Game of Thrones content in audio
form earlier than these video versions
or you might be listening to the audio
already and then you know well done yeah
if you if you're not though just look
for Westeros weekly on itunes or
wherever you get your podcast we've got
a lot of great stuff by the way in this
episode of course we're gonna answer all
your questions about what happened in
the episode what it all means we have
some other fun segments that we do every
week we have weekly Power Rankings all
kinds of stuff yes but we're gonna start
with the big question that is on all of
our minds
now our off-screen producer says that
this week yeah our question is coming to
us via the starter step oh all right
so but by the way this is just an app we
use a Stardust it's a social media app
that is specifically for film and TV
lovers you can share your video
reactions on there or you can actually
do text reactions there now too
that's where we pull our video questions
for the show from you just going to make
sure to tag us at new rockstar so we can
see it but let's get right into the
first one with at a hatch man 25 hey my
question is what's up with that new
weapon that aria wants Gendry to design
for her yes this is definitely what I
went into a full research mode about
last night
what is up with arias design for a new
secret weapon Eric remind us of this
moment yeah so this is from the very
quick moment in that reunion scene down
in the Winterfell forges where
this was a lot of faces we're coming
back together
one of them was Aria in the hound the
other one was Aria with Gendry you know
it was a bit awkward with the Hound
right well if you remember she did leave
him for dead she also robbed him which I
loved that she pointed that up she's
such a badass now and he was previously
on her kill list but then she said that
she took him off but also awkward with
ginjury in the way that like it's
awkward with your middle school crush oh
yeah when you went to the each other in
the halls of high school now yes it's
like now we're allowed to kiss and I
like the Hound was kind of like that
grizzled grib gym teacher who's kind of
like that's what you got to get out
right before the kids hit puberty oh
yeah so they they did put that on the
back burner so the Aria could ask Gendry
to make her a new weapon so of course
this is a new rockstar so we in in the
background before we started here we
zoom in enhanced zoomed in enhanced it
we zoomed it and you can see the diagram
it has some writing on it huh if you
look closely it would say dragonglass
on one part of it it also looks like it
has detachable pieces we know in terms
of weaponry Aria already has her her
sword needle and she also has a Valyrian
steel dagger the cat's paw dagger so why
would she need this third new weapon
okay well I have a few thoughts on why
she might need this new weapon you know
this is right after Aria saw the dragon
and she smiled and wonder right like
everyone else around her in wintertime
was freaking out running for cover
what is this fly in witchcraft she
seemed to be getting inspired to get an
idea well in the book she's obsessed
with a female dragon right right yeah
I'm sure a part of it is like oh man I'm
a writer dragon absolutely and this was
shortly after bran announced that the
night king himself has one of those
dragons as a weapon of his own so in the
footage which was news to Daenerys yes
by the way there was that looked at
exchange and I she kind of like kept it
together but that's very bad news that
she just received yes and this is also
after arya doesn't seem that proud of
all the killing when she's talking with
john he asks have you used it before and
she goes once or twice that kind of
awkward my
and you know maybe that that could mean
something more so there's a reason that
this has a dragonglass tip that's that's
clearly important she wrote dragonglass
on there she couldn't just tell him hey
the stuff that you're using currently
right now put that on the end of what I
want
this has to be dragonglass and maybe
she's done thinking about killing mortal
men and now she has her sights set on
killing immortal beasts are not
necessarily immortal but mythical beasts
like the dragon or specifically the
night king and/or his zombie dragon yes
absolutely okay so there are some very
cool possibilities that showed up in
some research about what the weapon
might be based on and also how it might
work
so specifically this is the thing I'm
leaning toward the most right now it
could be this kind of like homemade
detachable tip spear or harpoon this is
something that they they teach people in
classes of like you know if you ever
have to survive out in the wilderness
because you know your family dumped you
out there and you remember why to learn
the hard way yes I remember these these
lessons of things that you could do and
it's based on what ancient fishermen
used to use a detachable spear head to
hunt sea animals that you might be the
ones that like thrash around like seals
or sharks or your ancient dragons I
guess dragons they actually existed yes
not like a narwhal and made that thing
it could but the way it works is you can
also compare to another weapon where
just this idea of the projectile element
there's this Native American weapon
called and I believe it's called
a lottle a lottle it's a lot I think and
it's it's specifically a spear thrower
you know like they have dog tennis ball
throwers if you have like a wrist lash
effect where it launches it further yeah
kind of or like a deadly bowling Cup
game Paula Deen is deadly yeah right
yeah but the idea is that it throws the
spear further and faster than you would
be able to by hand so maybe up into the
air to hit a flying dragon or maybe to
hit someone riding a dragon this is also
the same episode where bran is bragging
he's the only he's the only man to ever
have shot a dragon
which could foreshadow the idea that
yeah maybe you'll stay the only man that
shoots a dragon but so she could
definitely be using this device at like
I mean you said specifically to take
down a dragon I actually have another
theory of like how specifically she
might be planning to use it okay so you
remember that we saw back in the season
8 trailer we were trying to study what
Aria was holding in the trailer okay
kind of looked like a spear right yeah
yeah I know we assumed that it could
just be a general spear but we also
talked about maybe it could be
dragonglass well let's assume yeah maybe
that's the dragon glass spear I think
Aria wants a weapon with this detachable
tip on one side and then spin it around
boom Valyrian steel dagger on the other
side a double-sided spear with the
projectile element built in it's like a
Swiss Army knife or I mean if you look
at this play it's worthy of like of
Darth Maul probably oh yeah that's
that's a great it's like Darth Maul feet
a lightsaber one side and then like a I
am just realizing that Darth Maul is
absolutely the night king he's got the
same horns anything that's like blue
himself yes yeah check it out ha ha ha
Tommy done by the way is the guy who
designs the weaponry for Game of Thrones
he said that he did build a specific
weapon for season 8 that was a
showstopper and a doozy and hubba-hubba
what uh but this could be that weapon
yeah and in the season 8 trailer you
could see while she's holding that
weapon arya says the words I know death
he's got many faces but I look forward
to seeing this one I could just be like
convenient trailer editing stuff that
they always loop stuff over but maybe
there's some greater significance to
this and I think the face she's
definitely talking about here I know
death I've seen it you know he has many
faces the the specific face is that of
the night king or Darth Maul or Darth
Maul in both cases but a little roll
face of death and I think she's going to
kill or at least try to kill the night
king with her new super spear that seems
to be her focus of it why else have it
tipped with dragonglass
yeah war Ward's at least try to kill him
yeah yeah I mean like who gets to kill
the night king is kind of a big thing
for all the characters I'm sure I have
reasons I think though that that would
make sense I know where just went to
different directions here about the
or the night king I think that the
that's the idea of this two-sided thing
yeah one side is to bring down his
dragon ride and the other is to give him
a new mouth on his neck yeah I can
always easily yeah I don't know I'm just
really looking forward to see how this
weapon
turns out this season how she's gonna
use it I'm assuming that we're also
going to see the hounds swing his new
dragon class acts which wasted so much
dragon glass so many people like most
people came 820 more arrowheads out of
this and said you got one big weapon
dies immediately also bran has that very
fancy crossbow that's gonna come into
play either way thank you to hatch man
25 rest and that starters question but
actually speaking to start us huge news
huge news this is so big I'm so excited
to tell you guys about this if you
download the Stardust app to share your
reactions and I also to ask us questions
about each episode and you tagged us at
new rock stars you might not only get
your question played on the episode of
this Westeros weekly like hatch man just
did you might get flown out here what
you you will get a few other people to
win this here you're gonna have flown
out to Los Angeles to watch the finale
of Game of Thrones with us live in
person at a special screening watch
party event Wow you will join us oh I'm
so excited
yes you're gonna you're gonna get to
meet us up close and personal oh don't
we sound interesting to media first and
you got to see what kind of puppets we
really are and who's pulling the strings
on us yeah you'll get to find out well
announce more details about the event
soon but specifically two lucky fans are
going to get their travel and
accommodations provided to hang out with
us and watch the show all you got to do
to enter is follow us on the App
Stardust you get one entry for doing
that and then you get another entry
every single time that you tag us on the
app so get to tag in yeah get to tagging
oh this is a great opportunity I'm so
excited this is how we met right like
yeah who you vote for each other's fans
if you have one contest for each other's
contest yeah and then yeah and then we
got our divorced parents back to fall in
love again yeah
yeah it's it's a great story you hear
all about it as we talk over the finale
episode of game up there
wait next question yes what is this
the Ravens are getting more and more
involved producers a jacked arm was in
Frank I didn't see it I only saw a very
furry Raven take that Ivan posted him
well here is the question at ally
cultivated asks do you think bran will
kill both Lannister brothers one of the
interesting reveals from this episode
yes a bran was given by Qyburn the fancy
crossbow that we've seen before on the
show technical name in in order to kill
for Cersei both Jamie and Tyrion yeah it
came in that very emotional reunion with
bran and prostitutes yes but this is a
really interesting question because bran
is obviously buddies with both of the
Lannister brothers all right so you
would think you wouldn't want to kill
them I know that when I was watching
everybody's like he's not gonna do it
right he wouldn't do it
but bran has been specifically always
motivated by money
yeah and that's exactly what she's
offering to him he sold out Tyrion
before in season four when Cersei bribed
him with a marriage to a noblewoman with
money in return for representing Tyrion
and trial by combat against a mountain
yeah a champion again he's like I've
been bought out sorry yeah exactly I was
like a higher bidder basically though
over and over from the first time he met
Bronn to last season in the dragon pit
tureen has said that if anyone ever
hires you Bronn to kill me I will pay
double
yeah and he told Jamie last season bran
tell Jamie last season after he saved
him from getting roasted by drogon till
I get what I'm owed a dragon doesn't get
to kill you you don't get to kill you
only I get to kill you so it's kind of a
it tells you where his mindset really is
at he's not necessarily a true loyal
companion and a friend this is a cell
sort through and through and all that
really motivates them is his gold so we
don't even though we see them together
and we kind of ship them in our heads
they must be friends because they went
on adventures together
bronze really only there because there's
a promise of payment in a castle at the
end and Jamie has reneged on his
promises to bran before and Circe's
Payne bran with a wagon
of gold right yeah outside a down
payment
that's more than jamie has ever done all
that Jamie gave him is this little bag
of gold on that Blackwater rush episode
in season seven maybe bran is a
different rules for different Lannister
boys and he will try to kill Jamie he
did teach them how to fight with one
hand maybe he knows how to beat him
because he didn't tell him a couple
tricks that he really does need to know
one handed fighter can only do so much
but before we continue quick sponsor
shout out to hellofresh he'll approach
is a meal kit delivery service set shops
plans and delivers step-by-step recipes
and pre measured ingredients so that you
can just cook and eat and enjoy as we
all should only have to worry about
hellofresh makes conquering the kitchen
a reality with deliciously simple
recipes they do all the meal planning
and shopping and prepping so that you
can just focus on a healthier you and a
happier family and spend less time meal
planning and grocery shopping so that
you can spend more time just doing what
you love watching starts videos there
are three plans to choose from there is
a classic plan veggie and a family plan
and there's an option to switch if your
tastes change over time I personally
really enjoyed how hellofresh has
simplified my whole dinnertime
I love the recipes I just got delivery
there was like a pork carnitas tacos was
so good and apricot glazed chicken stuff
that I would normally not to think to
shop for by myself but they prepped it
all for me and I could just go and it
was awesome delicious and it has become
hands-down my favorite meal kit delivery
service for $80 off your first month of
hellofresh go to hellofresh comm slash
rockstars 80 and enter the promo code
rockstars 80 it's like receiving eight
meals for free you can just go to hell
of fresh comm slash rockstars 80 and
enter the promo code rockstars 84 $80
off your first month of hellofresh meal
delivery kits before we get to the next
question a quick shout out to another
great sponsor is helping us bring this
show to you bran isn't the only person
who cares about money you also care
about money and making more of it Robin
Hood is an investing app that lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and Kryptos all commissioned
free while other brokerages charge up to
$10 for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge any Commission fees so you can
trade stocks and keep all of your
profits plus there is no account minimum
deposit needed to get started so you can
start investing at
any level the simple intuitive design of
Robin Hood makes investing easy for
newcomers and experts alike view easy to
understand charts and market data and
place a trade in just four taps on your
smartphone you can also view stock
collections such as the hundred most
popular with Robin Hood you can learn
how to invest in the market as you build
your portfolio discover new stocks track
your favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price movements so you
never missed the exact right moment to
invest Robin Hood is giving listeners of
Knox there's a free stalk like Apple or
Ford or sprint to help you build your
portfolio all you gotta do is sign up at
rockstars dot Robin Hood com again
that's rockstars dot Robin Hood com
there you can sign up and get a free
stock yeah that's great no idea what we
were acting - yes but a raven just
smacked Eric in the face like Fabio all
those years ago ok at Stasha mia Stasha
asks why did Cersei sleep with your on
yeah this was interesting right and we
don't want to shame her for her choices
but it's an interesting it seems a
little out of character for Cersei to
want to do this a little out of
character with who she was at the
beginning of that scene so why did she
change her mind suddenly well we do know
that from Lancel Lannister that Cersei
doesn't necessarily mind sleeping with
someone just for a good time but really
the reason she slept with Lance's
because he reminded her so much of Jaime
at least that's what we found is like a
young Jaime a young Jaime and even
younger version who she can better
control and used to do her bidding now
we heard and you're on ships scene with
Yara that he's not super loyal to Cersei
he just wants to hook up with a queen
and maybe Cersei knows it the only way
to keep him on her side it's just just
let him in her bedroom just once just
one time just like shut him up he's not
gonna shut up yeah of course I mean he's
gonna like talk about this too but also
somebody I was watching with was like
really just to sleep with a queen and I
was like are you kidding me a queen if
Queen Elizabeth were here right now I
would I would beg you just committed
treason I wouldn't take it hey we've got
a war so we don't have to respect your
mana I did I'm 300 years old it's
telling of what's really going
here when Euron's just a creepy thing of
rubbing her belly yeah you know yeah and
then as one says I'm going to put a
little prince and he yes which you said
that to me boy doll pillow talk yeah
which I definitely immediately thought
of like Prince this is singer but I did
a little baby Prince wouldn't be there's
no cuddling look after but okay so
you're on isn't actually putting
anything in there right because she is
supposed to already be pregnant so
that's the look that she has on her face
so either she's keep taking that into
account or she's about to ruin their
life you also wonder if Sir sees using
Euron as like a fake father for her
pregnancy
you know she's no longer on the same
side as Jamie and she told Jamie last
season he asked who are you going to say
as a father and she says you of course
but now he's abandoned her so she can't
really do that anymore it would be kind
of awkward so maybe she needs like a new
kind of father figure for this for this
baby another powerful man in Westeros
and say he's the father and you know
let's be honest when you're depressed
that you didn't get any murder elephants
with your new army you gotta make some
decisions somewhere in there it's just
gonna happen naturally I think that she
is is not really looking for a father
figure for this baby though right I
don't think she respects father figures
she's always been like you know not not
seen as worthy by her own father figure
and then Robert wasn't a great dad
either but I do think that there is
something about claiming that this baby
is is your aunt and maybe you know as
far as she knows he still has that claim
to the Iron Islands yeah he doesn't
understand that yeah we're talking about
like the public version of Cersei versus
a private version publicly she probably
wants like to secure the throne by
having like another noble born father to
this baby so that she can say say this
baby is legitimate so that the line of
succession is secured as is her power in
that myth that she's right you know it's
the same plan as Chris Martin and
Gwyneth Paltrow oh absolutely yeah Apple
to the throne apple tree growth yeah
oh what's this
Oh Oh Thank You Raven @h McHale Hess
wants to know why does the night King
make that spiral symbol okay well just
to remind you guys but let's let's pour
one out for the only person with a name
to die this episode poor Ned umber
people named Ned have really no chance
in the world of Game of Thrones and he's
named after Ned Stark oh yes he is
deliberately named after Ned Stark so
don't don't name your kid Ned's unless
you want to be better off Ned no what I
wanna acknowledge is that so there's all
those body parts with Ned and him he's
kind of crucified in the middle there
and it makes the spiral symbol we that
is a familiar symbol yes we've seen that
north of the wall at the fist of the
first men we saw when John showed Dany
the cave at Dragonstone we we just
haven't necessarily given it meaning yet
yes we only loosely know what it means
now it's it's not in the books
they'll never describe you know a world
spiral pattern appearing on the wall
it's a new invention for the show but
you know and the White Walkers in the
themselves are not very good at
explaining what they're all about
they're kind of you know cats got their
tongue but people have brought up in
this episode that the flaming spiral at
least from a viewer standpoint looks
very similar to the Targaryen sigil
which has dragon heads three dragon
heads and tails and arms that kind of
form a similar spiral pattern which I
believe in the past Philip you've
described as an octopus when it gets
angry it just spins around real fast
spikey that's my favorite description of
what this is but the reason why this is
it could be important is you know is
there a connection here and even if the
night king doesn't intend there to be a
connection to the show did the producers
say hey there's a reason this looks
similar there's a reason that we
specifically show this image of the
night king this spiral on fire this
episode which you know Targaryen fire in
blood that's their whole symbolism and
their imagery and they have made a point
about talking about sigils earlier in
this episode remember Tyrion saw the
Karstarks their starburst sigil and he
said you know they're socials out there
at least it's not an onion it does kind
of look like a nut
splayed open if you go to Outback
Steakhouse we get the Miss sponsor oh
boy I love those yeah we haven't had
lunch yet most of the evidence that we
have about what's going on with this
symbol aisle revolves specifically
around the children of the forest who
made the White Walkers are the first
white walkers at a place with stones in
that same spiral shape yeah and so what
I think is really interesting this plot
stood out to me when we do you see that
image of little little Ned number which
is a terrible children's story to tell
in the future little Ned numbers he's
impaled through the chest just like the
first white Walker yeah with dragonglass
also if you kind of take a look at this
image when we first see it it's obscured
a bit by the tree but at the center of
the world is where this is happening
yeah where the night king is being made
essentially that same centers where we
find little net number it feels like
maybe they're implying that everything's
headed back there to where the children
were not necessarily to where it
originally happen vote to that a concept
of where it all started where he was
made maybe to to unmake something or to
make a whole new race of things we don't
know but all we know right now is that
at the least it's a really sick way to
make some sort of warning yeah but it
might not be a warning just for the
people up north there might be a warning
for the children the horse yeah I'm
coming for you did he's a kid yeah he
could have used any of the other adults
who lived there at a last hearth but he
used the kid yeah which is interesting
that actually that the pointing that out
the kid is technically the head of that
household yes at the time which I feel
like it's probably part of it too he's
like I'm taking the the person who has
the reins here I maybe that's part of it
too you know
that would put Jon Snow in his sights or
Daenerys or someone who also is holding
some sort of high-ranking I don't think
Cersei I don't know like I don't think
he even cares that she exists either way
the knight Kings cutting some promo I'm
coming for you other kids in northern
house you're trying to work this in and
every time a wrestling impression
wrestling's amazing oh here's an hour
[Music]
he really wants us to ask these
questions okay so at SM polymerize asks
what's up with the what's up with
dragons look while John into Harry and
Eric's for kissing and at bay k-50 asks
what's up with brands look when Jamie
arrives in Winterfell
yeah there's a lot interesting glances
going on this episode right so drogon
was giving that look to John maybe he's
pissed because someone's making out with
his mom and that's just weird
like any kid when mom brings home a new
boyfriend yeah he's like okay fine you
may be able to ride my brother but I'm
not cool with this even if it is in
front of an awesome-looking waterfall
hey this isn't Lisa Frank enough for me
and I miss that this is happening right
now and I will never accept you as my
new dad I'm glad you're finally able to
talk about all that yeah it's been a
long journey I here's one thing that I
think is fun I remember who drogon is
named after Khal Drogo oh yeah that's
right yeah I think it's kind of like if
the spirit of Khal Drogo is anywhere and
it's watching his girl get taken by a
much less cow type guy yeah I mean he
might be giving that little bit about
reason too yeah that's an interesting
thought now as for the shot with Jamie
and bran that other interesting look
this is the first time they have met
since the first episode of the series
remember when Jen just Jamie just pushed
bran out of a window and brand told Sam
earlier that they were he was waiting
for an old friend in the courtyard hours
earlier that alone I guess they need to
put some wheelchair ramps up in
Winterfell because otherwise that guy's
not going anywhere
but apparently that old friend was Jaime
Lannister it's interesting to describe
him that way
bran told everyone that they didn't have
time for any nonsense at the beginning
this episode it's like no time for
greetings I'm going to ruins everyone
everyone stay with the worst possible
information and maybe that applies to
his viewing of Jaime as well because the
night Kings coming and he's basically
not doing anything for the rest of this
episode right he convinced Samwell Tarly
to go talk to John he seems to be like
waiting for some other bigger reason
he's like I don't time to deal with that
stuff
you guys deal with this stuff I have a
more important thing on the horizon yeah
I think that he did
moment that he says old friend Oh kind
of foreshadows that he's not gonna he's
not gonna do what what the rest of us
would do yeah really a rub is making us
disabled in his face I think he's he
says old friend because he's just like
yeah we have we have a history but maybe
there's actually a much bigger part that
Jamie has boy and he's excited to
finally bring this this figure into the
battle and kind of fill him in on what
he needs him to do he couldn't even
technically I don't know be some amount
of grateful for Jamie's role in getting
brand to fulfill his destiny of becoming
but yeah I don't know I mean we saw a
little bit in the preview next time that
it seems like a lot of people are gonna
be upset with Jamie I think it wouldn't
be so shocking of brands actually the
one that stands up for his new Lannister
friend yes I will not press charges or
blink every yeah yeah well now let's
move on to our Power Rankings right so
we we've been talking a lot about all
the great questions so you guys have
been sending and thank you so much they
were all amazing but now it's the part
of show you guys decide for us it's a
game of Thrones Power Rankings you voted
in our poll on Twitter for who you
thought won the episode last night and
we got our results in yeah and this
wasn't a really interesting episode for
it because there weren't any battles
none of our parties made huge moves at
least so the vote actually ended up
being pretty evenly split between a
couple of major characters so it's
starting with third place we've got
Sansa Stark okay so he has 15% of the
vote uh pretty powerful episode for her
like she was able to tell Tyrion I
thought you were the smartest person
alive I guess I was wrong yeah like a
sense of snark right yeah sure she like
definitely is the one at least at the
top in that way yeah um but I don't
necessarily wasn't my vote so second
place is bran Stark 16 percent of the
vote
he definitely disturbed the most people
yeah I mean it was interesting to see
that reversal where in the first episode
of the series it would ended on brands
terrified faces being pushed out a
window now it's been reversed in Jaime
is the most terrified person so that's
definitely a Power Move their problem
also we
telling your brother when he says you're
a man now and he says almost what what
does that mean is that like the Britney
Spears lyric yeah he didn't say you know
I'm more than that or I'm not a man he
said almost like he's like he's hoping
that he gets laid soon herself I no
longer identify with humanity I identify
he's a tree
but speaking of who he was talking to
the easy first-place vote goes to Jon
Snow with 21 percent of the vote yeah
and it's interesting cuz he kind of
showed power in a couple different ways
this episode of course he rode a dragon
which is always a Power Move on the show
but also pretty powerful in his reaction
to learning about his true lineage and
his true identity he kind of had this
interesting almost like stealing to to
is like demeanor well yeah and he didn't
he doesn't want the crown so that kind
of not neglecting the responsibility but
saying there are bigger problems it
doesn't matter anymore I don't need to
be king I'm giving up my crown in order
to save my people really nothing is more
powerful and more honorable than that
but and then when he does find out you
do see the the glint in his eye that
this could actually matter right because
there's the interesting fact that he has
been over being a bastard for a long
time and you know I think that's very
honorable and respectful respectful but
it's kind of like oh yeah yeah but what
if you never were a bastard the whole
time does that change things for you and
it almost seems like it might it's kind
of like if you have like huge scar in
your face and you're like oh it doesn't
bother me and then like someday
someone's just like oh it was just
chocolate and they smeared avi ago thank
God did you see in the first episode in
the first couple episodes of the first
season jon was all about dealing and
struggling with this idea of being a
bastard and what's his place in the
world and finally he seems to have
gotten over that he doesn't care anymore
because he has another purpose but now
sam has kind of thrown this back in his
face like oh you're not a bastard you're
a king he's like dang it I don't have to
worry about what my title is anymore I'm
back in the situation this now it's too
much responsibility and I hate that I
have to deal with this now so he's kind
of dealing with the same kind of
conflict it wasn't different what he
really hates that he has to deal with
now is is he knows it's gonna be trouble
between him and Daenerys right was
foreshadowed by Barris yeah yeah it
nothing lasts and this is just a further
complication
that distracts them from the real goal
well we have no updates this week on our
death pool contest because no one died
besides net number he wasn't on our and
and there were some Greyjoy's who died
on the silent but they were all unnamed
as well they're they're mutes so they
couldn't even tell us what their name is
yes you're on cuts their tongues out but
I will say that on my death pool fee if
you find mine I will say the first
person who I said dies is your on
Greyjoy so do I get points the fact that
his men were the first characters to die
oh no no okay
no no no trying but you explained that
but you guys might to make sure to keep
submitting to the death pool yeah I
guess the throne calm and look up the
Westeros weekly death pool but real
quick first we gotta say a quick thank
you to our sponsor post mates it's ten
minutes before one of the final Game of
Thrones episode starts and you want some
wine to drink along with Tyrion while he
makes fun of various for you know not
having genitals that kind of fun so what
do you do you downloaded postmates sap
for iOS or android for free and you get
whatever you want delivered year-round
you can browse local stores and
restaurants and track your delivery post
mates is gonna bring you what you want
within the hour 24 hours a day 365 days
a year food groceries whatever you need
delivered they have the largest
on-demand merchant network in the entire
known universe which I don't know how
they prove that but I believe it the
only thing they can't deliver is Game of
Thrones spoilers and theories which is
why you're here now so for a limited
time postmates is giving our listeners
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first seven days to start those free
deliveries you download the app right
now you use code rockstars
so specifically again that's code
rockstars for 100 freakin dollars or
free delivery credit for your first
seven days when you download the post
Knights app you get anything you need
anytime you need it download post mates
save with the code rockstars great what
a great deal yeah but we're gonna end
every episode of Westeros weekly looking
at the teaser for next week's episode
and we're gonna give you our predictions
for some of what we think is gonna
happen we won't get too spoilery don't
worry when I was a child my brother
would tell me a bedtime story
about the man who murdered our Father
but all the things we would do to that
man
he never should have trusted sir see you
never should have over death thought
many faces and look forward to seeing
this one
I don't we have
before the Sun comes up tomorrow
[Music]
ooh that last shot especially with that
I've got two things to say about that
last shot one is I think that's gonna be
the end of the next episode I think this
episode seems like it's gonna be setting
the table for the Battle of Winterfell
so that you know looking at or near the
end of licking at it maybe finally
seeing the armies but the other thing I
want to point out is this is something
that happens in color grading in general
across film and TV but they're
definitely pushing it now in this final
season of Game of Thrones is orange
versus blue
oh yeah which is that fire versus ice
all rights also our alma mater scullers
yeah but I think just keep an eye out
for them for that self um would you see
in there I think it's just again this is
another like table setting up so like
how big is this freaking table on Game
of Thrones well we know episode 3 will
be the Battle of Winterfell not this
episode so I'm thinking they're not
showing us things that are happening on
other parts of Westeros some drama down
south and King's Landing
some drama maybe with the Greyjoy's and
I think that might be some bigger things
going on so hopefully we'll be seeing
some twists with what Circe's plan could
be or what's really going on with your
on the whole golden company and how is
he going to respond to losing Yara will
that blow up in his face so it's for me
it's what's not in this promo that I'm
most curious about all right so before
we just wrap up here Eric wanting you
give a little tease of the kinds of
stuff you're working on this week for
yes our our breakdown I'm so excited I'm
kind of midway through writing it some
of the stuff we talked about here like
the whole night Kings sigil what kind of
messages he sent trying to send out I
have a couple other thoughts really I'm
most excited to point out all the
specific ways this episode was almost a
shot-for-shot recreation of the first
episode of the series we talked about
some of the ways but it's almost down to
like specific lines of dialogue
character choices restage and moments
with new characters and the music
Ramin Djawadi composed some really
interesting musical like motifs remind
us of specific things that hint to how
the characters relationships have
changed and there's also just some like
little connections to the book and to
past episodes that surprised me and we
found out what happened Ed Sheeran's
character so we'll we talked about that
as well
in the breakdown also just real quick we
talked about a lot of new stuff in the
new intro for this show oh yeah
and if you look closely you might have
seen some very interesting new dragons
at the four dragons they showed some
like tabloids of famous historical
intimate stuff that you're also gonna
get into this way yeah but that's it for
this episode of Westeros weekly so thank
you so much for watching or listening
don't forget to subscribe to both the
new rock stars channel for ongoing Game
of Thrones coverage but also
specifically to the west of Westeros
weekly podcast where you can get
everything that we just talked about the
Eric was saying is gonna put out that's
all gonna come out on the podcast first
and then it could be a few hours later
on the channel some of it's gonna be
maybe a few days later on the channel
make sure to follow us on twitter at new
rock stars and tweet us your questions
for every episode as we go through the
season with the hashtag Westeros weekly
and also on the stardust app tagged us
at new rock stars and we'll feature your
questions on there too and you'll be
entered to win you come watch sorry so
much pizza follow me at fimo on Twitter
and fo Moline on Instagram yeah and you
can follow me on twitter and instagram @
ee vos thanks for watching and listening
this week guys and I'm so hyped already
for episode three oh three and five bye
guys
[Music]